all right hello everyone this is uh this
is something a little different for some
of you guys so as you see in my
inventory we got a little bit of money
I'm going to have to uh you know just
kind of ball out and sell off some of
this [__] that I got rolling around in
my bank and you guys are about to see
the first worthless to Wall Street
episode for some of you that I have made
in a long time some of you guys have
never seen this uploaded on my channel
which is pretty insane I'm just going to
go sell off a couple items and then I'll
explain to you guys what this series is
all about so let's get into that here in
a second all right so as you can see
here sold off my primordials and my
Arcane Spirit Shield got 120 mil which
is what we ended off the uh 15th episode
with going to throw this on over to my
other account and we will move swiftly
on all right so for those of you that
were unaware of what this series is
about um well feel free to meet large
exp lamp he's my friend he's going to be
merching for us but uh yeah this series
is a series in which I started with 5
mil and I decided that I would merch
everything from the grand exchange and
now uh yeah we're not 5 mil anymore
probably be better if I showed you guys
the other account
right all right there we go we'll work
that in all right so as you can see 120
mil it's pretty lit we're going to put
in the bank pin find some offers let's
get this [__] going I'm happy to be back
all right so there's been one item that
I've actually been really um just I
don't know aching to actually try to
merch um I probably missed the best
points to Merch this item but it is the
imbu heart one of the reasons I feel
that it's very good is because the price
range is also really low so no one
actually has a real ideas to far as to
what it buys and sells for unless you
look it up so that's something that
factors in a little bit right now OS
Buddy says the buy and the sell is 59
mil and the recently traded price like
for the hour right here says 60.5 on the
OS buddy site says 58.5 so I'm all sorts
of confused I don't know what I want to
do so I'm just going to go with 58 569k
and we're going to try to buy two of
them see how that goes and uh hopefully
I just don't lose Bank you know all
right all right we'll take it but this
is overnight we bought one for 60 mil
pretty much on the dot and right now
they're selling on for
61.8 so that's pretty [__] good 1.8
mil profit I will definitely take that
um wish another one would be able to buy
I don't know what I want to up it to
because I know that these prices are
pretty unstable right now so I don't
know if I want to get stuck with one but
uh yeah this should be pretty cool I
don't know made 2 mil already pretty
badass right right right all right so we
ended up ending
all right so we ended up selling off the
imbued heart for 61.5 mil so we made 1.5
mil on that it's not looking like
there's going to be too much of a merch
on it anymore but we're going to see
what we can do right now there's really
no guide prices on it so I don't have
anything to go by and the margin seem
pretty small so we're going to move on
to something else all right so I've been
blowing
ass on these [__] Ferro sors merges
so as you can see on the first one even
finding the margin boom 650k loss then I
end up getting a little bit of my
dignity back with a 200k profit then as
you can see I got a 350k profit and then
I inst sold one of these for 8 mil the
one that I bought so I made like 70k off
of that somehow I think I'm up like
[__] 100K or some [__] so we're going
to try to get a little bit of those but
I can't just [__] merch these forever
so I'm going to find some ultro items no
no okay other items other items not
Spanish there you go B some margins
there we go 120k margin on internal
crystals and 160 170k margin on
tyrannical rings so we'll see if these
buy or sell I'm not going to do any math
on what I would make I have no [__]
clue if they are going to buy or sell so
here we
go what the
[__] okay there we go look at this [__]
look at this [__] I made [__] I don't
know 170k cuz I had to buy one of those
but look at this bro 8 mil and I sold
four of them off so that's a 1.4 mil
profit # [__] lit let's go all right
so A lot's happened boys um in the time
of making this video to now the uh
Cleveland Indians have blew a 3-1 lead
that's great it's great I don't know I
mean I like the Cavs I'm kind of an
Indian supporter so it was kind of
[__] but here we go enough of that so
as you can see I bought two tyrannical
rings for around there ended up making
170k off of both of them then bought
four more made 170k off of all of those
all right then [__] it decided to merge
some Ferro sors as you can see
812k there and I can sell them on for
8246 also back here I made 350k on four
of them so that's a lot of money but uh
margins went down a little bit I'm going
to make sure that the price is still
8246 and we're going to sell these on
here in a second all right 8198 is
actually the price so we're only making
about 100K off of all those that's not
too bad right 8198 we can deal with that
hopefully those all sell overnight so as
I'm saying overnight I will probably
going to bed here in a second so uh yeah
[__] it we got six of these we'll sell
them on for something around I don't
know 5649 is and uh that'll give us 129k
profit on or 25k profit on all those all
right just woke up as you can see we
pretty much got like [__] I don't know
we we're able to sell off everything but
one which is kind of annoying so I'm
going to have to see what these prices
are and what I can buy something for and
[__] whatever I'm just going to buy
and sell one of the Ferro scepter so I
know what I can buy them for and uh yeah
we're going to we're going to do a
little bit more of this though 8.1
that's not bad we're going to sell this
on see if there's any decent money to be
made e
and I mean 97k isn't bad but really I
mean it's not the greatest especially
for the risk you take with these because
these are way over their Med price and
they shot up yesterday so I'm going to
stay away from those the tyranical ring
I'm probably just going to sell on for
like I don't know something I know I
could sell it for so like 5 six oh okay
something like that we'll see what we'll
see what happens we'll see we'll see
we'll see we'll see all right so as you
can see here here nine of the feros sors
bought I don't know what they're buying
for now earlier I couldn't get them to
buy for 8.7 mil I'm going to assume that
that's not the case anymore however if
it okay well it still is so I am still
going to try to sell them on for that
cuz that would be inane but yeah I doubt
many of sell for that but we'll try it
all right so TR lost some of the pharoh
scepter as you can see weren't able to
really sell them so going to go ahead
and buy one see what it buys for and
then we're going to sell it on for that
all right we'll see if that buys that
should buy so 8269 which means we can
sell all of ours off for that so 8269 K
and that would put us at 57.8 mil plus
this we're probably at 127 128 mil as
you can see I'll just go back through
these real quick basically the only
thing I did was just flip a few of these
I actually was able to sell a couple off
for like 700k profit and then some more
off for like 2 to 300K profit so it was
pretty good all right here I am boys in
the morning so all the tyrannical rings
have sold all the Eternal boots have
sold we weren't able to buy much of
anything and the Ferro sceps have not
sold which is a little disappointing um
I'm going to see how much I can make off
of these super stores though so as you
can see here spent
13.6 66 mil holy [__] um oh my God
[__] alarm all right we'll move
swiftly on so add on about 5k because
one of these Isn't decanted So
930 and as you can see
13.94% pretty [__] quick so then I
was like well the guy price says it's
8.3 so I'm going to check again was able
to buy one for 8.2 so if I'm able I mean
I just charge all these so if I'm able
to sell them on for 8.2 I'm going to
make about a mill more than I was about
to end up selling them all for for no
profit so let's hope for the best all
right might be a little bit of
background noise because of uh the
traffic my windows open but everything
[__] sold off so let's collect
everything and we'll see where we are at
why is that not the right amount of
money that would be why there we go 127
mil and 86k pretty lit pretty lit all
right so two imbued hearts spot 57.9 mil
apparently they can sell on for 58.1 but
I'm going to try to go a little higher
like
58 198k something like that that'll make
us about 400 C both of them and 800k in
total then so there we go it was at this
moment that he knew he [__] up all
right so as I was able to I don't I just
woke up but I was able to sell off both
of the imbued hearts and yeah we lost
about
180k is on both of them um I'm okay with
that though because if I didn't sell
them on for that they dropped even more
like even a few 100K more I don't know
what it was but for some reason they
just dropped right after I got them so
we'll move on to something else all
right so I am back I went to a Ohio
State Nebraska football game and holy
[__] was that a [__] mess but uh
tried to buy an armadel hillt just
because I'm sure that there were not a
lot of those selling bought some [__]
compost potion hoping for a flip and
beart did not buy however necklace of
anguishes I was able to make as you can
see down here I was able to make 300K
cuz I did have to buy the margin um that
was my Xbox apologies for that and I
also made 80k on a torture ornament kit
flip so I accidentally inst sold it and
that is why I didn't make more than that
so we'll find some more items I guess
because that didn't go as planed I was
hoping that the abute heart would
actually byy all right so we found some
items as you can see I was able to
actually merge some more archers before
these ones I have about a 90 or an 80 to
90k margin and I merg four of them um so
I made like I don't know probably like
close to 300K because or I mean a little
less than 300K cuz I actually had to buy
the margin but another three of bought
which means we hit our limit of 8 in an
hour we will sell these on and in total
probably make about 600k or so from The
Archers Rings which is pretty [__]
cool considering these actually don't
usually have that much of a margin like
they used to be insanely good to merch
and then have gone downhill so um
they're decent right now and I will take
advantage of that I'm going to throw
these up and I'll tell you guys about
the other items that we have going on
Ferro sors currently have about a 200k
margin and tyrannical rings as you can
see here 170k which is actually pretty
crazy um ended up selling that off so I
haven't made any profit so far off of
the tyrannical Rings because I actually
had to buy the margins but uh yeah also
shout out to uh few metric for uh
hitting me up as always you guys can
message me in game if I get too many
messages I might not respond to all of
but I'll do my best all right so I mean
the only real thing to see here I guess
is that my tyrannical rings have sold or
at least two of them and I was able to
buy another three so I'll sell those on
for 5 771k and we'll be making about
170k is off of all or off of each one of
these so I probably made close to 7 800k
off of all these in total all right so
here we go so we have an imbued heart
that bought for 50 59 mil I believe I
can sell it on for around 59.8 which
would be actually a pretty decent merch
and I think the best that I've had in
this video or at all for a while with
the imbued heart um some of the Ferro
sors have sold off a few more need to
sell obviously the problem with this
with this item is they are just very
unreliable for the most part like if you
end up getting a lot of them more than
likely you're going to get undercut
constantly and the prices of them are
just going to go down as far as the toms
of fire I was able to sell on a lot of
them for six or 643k I don't have the
initial Buy price although I was I I
think it was around 600k for the most
part so I think I made around 3 to 400k
on all that I was making a lot more
earlier probably made about 6 700k off
of them before that and uh yeah that's
where we are so I'm also buying
cannonballs I probably should just throw
some money on this account for my main
and just have it be as a side thing
because I'm actually buying these for my
main but just for you guys I have no
logical explanation as to why
cannonballs have dropped so much they
had a sharp drop recently I would
imagine some sort of Bot dump or someone
with was hoarding them and decided to
dump them but even at this point they've
been 200 GP for the longest time and 200
is way too low they typically are around
230 to 250 I would imagine or at least
you can find them at spikes of that I
would imagine within the next month or
two so if you have a lot of spare change
or you want to make a decent amount of
money with some unused Cash go ahead and
buy cannonballs I would say at this
point if you can get them for 180 it's a
relatively safe bet because cannoning is
so helpful for Slayer but uh if they end
up going to like 210 220 don't quote me
on anything cuz that may be the highest
that they reach I don't know if it has
anything to do with some sort of blast
furnace type method but yeah I'm just
buying some of these all right it will
sell on another Ferro scepter and as you
can see the bigger reason that I'm
recording this is we sold off the inbu
heart for good 800k merch so I'm going
to go ahead and get another one and then
we'll go from there all right so able to
buy on four more Ferro sors which I'm
not sure was a good idea or not consider
I I just say idea um anyways so yeah not
sure if it was a good idea or not
because these have not sold yet so I'm
just going to drop keep dropping the
price on these and eventually hopefully
they'll sell also able to buy another
imbued heart so probably going to sell
that on and hopefully make a little bit
of money that way and uh yeah I know the
flips have kind of been repetitive but
they've been pretty good so I'm sticking
with them all right so a will sell on
the imbued heart for 60.9 mil as I uh
mentioned earlier and right now
apparently if this is right we can buy
an imbu heart for 59 .2 mil which would
be a pretty insane merch if that's true
and then I could sell it on for 61.2 so
literally a 2 mil merge right there if I
can get that to go through and again
boom Another imbued heart bought we're
going to see what we can sell it on for
I'm refreshing the OS buddy price guide
right now and uh it is saying
61.5 mil which is actually pretty insane
I'm going to go and try to list it up
for 6189 okay though I'm going to go a
little higher I'm going to go a little
higher they did just kind of Spike for
some reason over the last couple hours
it kind of went up a lot I don't have
any you know logical reasoning behind it
but realistically I bought this for 6.2
mil so there's no way that I should lose
money on it and if I could make 1.7 mil
that'd be pretty [__] sick all right
so able to sell on the imbued heart as
you can see able to make a mail there um
got pretty actually pretty lucky with
that because it dropped pretty much
right after I was able to buy my last or
the last time I bought the imbu heart
one of the problems I'm seeing right now
though is we still cannot sell off these
[__] Ferro scepter and I do not
understand why that is I don't I don't
get why none of these are buying or
selling or anything like these things
are just dropping a ton and yeah I don't
I'm losing like 100k on some of them
like I don't I don't know I just I
figured overnight I would be able to at
least sell a few of them but [__] all
right so there we go pretty much sold
off everything and uh we had some good
flips on the Eternal Corel R will flip
four for about a 200k profit the AR
Rings were about 20K each so I made 140k
off of that in the tyranical Rings I
made you know like 120k because I had to
flip one to find the margins so we're
going to collect all the money that we
have and [__] all right so there we go
tyrannical Rings kind of dropped on me a
little bit but this is where we are
going to end off the video so these
cannonballs I also bought with my own
money so we can add those on they go for
about 2008 GP so we're going to add on
4.3 mil to whatever this price check is
and as you can see
129 pretty much 4 mil so that means once
you add it together we ended off the
video with
133.7k out a lot shows a little bit of
support there as well but with that
being said nonetheless hope you guys
have a wonderful day and peace and holy
[__] worthless to Wall Street is
[Music]
oh